we're starting hello everybody welcome
to Thursday morning stream you guys
could all hear a moment there before we
went live I'm Sam I'm Shasta hi how are
you guys and today we are playing
vermintide 2 from Tide DOS with the band
which I don't know can they you're back
yes they can hear been in the game once
we get the game audio running but yes
Ben would be our dwarf I am playing as
the elf and I not sure who Eric's gonna
be playing as but we've got a team of 3
so we'll be playing with one random
person yeah that we set up with but it's
a team of four
yes very similar to left 4 dead but
you're killing all these bad rat boys
yes and I feel like left 4 dead I guess
the first one came out in 2008 second
one I don't know what bad with years I'm
bad with yours too but a lot of people
probably I don't know I feel like it's
been a long time so anybody has played
left 4 dead yeah so I'm I recently
played it last year just because I like
playing as groups but this is super
exciting because now I can play this
game with my friends watching that and
we are teaming up together all right I'm
gonna switch over here I'm gonna pull up
the game audio a little bit cool so I
got my dwarf there's a there's been no
been ok Eric's joining us let's see who
he has chosen I'll show you guys
yeah so I'm playing the handmaiden and
Ben is playing the Slayer and as you can
see I have a passive the dance of
seasons which increases my dog dodge
distance and then my career skill is the
- nice
I believe Eric is asking you to add him
on the steam AJ ok also hold on just a
moment yeah so that you guys can all get
a party together here a little friends
all of a sudden I have 1 million slack
messages that everything is okay and
nothing is actually on fire ok limo and
then they all disappeared and I don't
know why we got this but yeah - it's
fairly new and I've been playing since
the beta but like not that much like a
little bit each night it's actually how
I wind down after a day of work
Berman's I yeah I love that
it's surprisingly calming like even
though you're just killing hordes of
rats you're just hacking and slashing
away so it's just it's very chill for me
and I enjoy it
where is Eric Eric is joining the game
let's see who he populates as hello
everybody I wanted to have a choice
before we have someone else join us yes
definitely and also hello rejoining
there some people are beginning a
personal shout outs a year old
there he is look at that boy
oh he stepped on my head what a jerk all
right what a jerk yeah so vermintide to
you play in groups of four if you're not
familiar with it
like I said fairly similar to left for
dead but we're gonna do some quick play
matches we can get set up with someone
really quick there's a bunch of
different maps a bunch of different
difficulties but since everyone's fairly
new we're gonna start with the main
difficulty that you start off with which
is recruits
there's veteran champion and legend are
the other ones we are sticking with
recruit don't worry just artist I wanna
lie I've only played up to veterans so
far but it's it's rough so really I went
to play this last night in preparation
because I was like everyone please
confirm very excited 25 gig game pretty
big so I wasn't able to download it but
I'm really excited to see you guys jump
into it cuz I hear everybody's having a
lot of fun with it
yes why isn't it letting me play and
play there we go alright everything they
have to confirm it on their hands and
then this bubble will pop up and we all
hang out by the waist down and then we
wait for someone to either get a bot
which is probably what's going to happen
to play as our witch or wizard who
throws fireballs righteous stands so
there's a lot of different maps they're
a lot of fun they only had a few in the
beta but then I really like what
happened when they drop the final game
there's a lot of really cool gross
looking maps nice like a bunch of
corpses there's one that's completely in
the dark and have to follow your cart to
keep it the light it sounds scary to me
it's a little scary but I don't know why
I find this calming like my my former
just hack and slash game was a killing
floor 2 so the nice I love Killing Floor
2 that was so much fun that game it was
like I feel like there was a ton of hype
when it first came out and like it sort
of died off but it was yeah it's so much
fun I loved it and I find it super
common yeah me too
I really love that game if I want to
play with you know yeah we're chilling
yeah we totally [ __ ] I could I could
pick it up anytime yeah that's so you
know it is you have to remain so calm
and like collected throughout your day
and you just like yeah turn wise all
your stress so at the end of the day you
just want like you know smash some
bodies okay there's a healing drought if
anyone needs it I don't think anyone's
gotten hurt yet but yeah that's how you
heal up there's either medical supplies
or healing droughts human droughts are
stronger says here we're getting I
dropped our mic audio a little bit okay
so me am i I'm not sure cube what do you
let us know
yeah let's go this way and also when
you're in these maps they have different
books that you can collect to raise your
score by the end of it your team score
they have three homes and then I believe
and then and then two grim which are
harder to find oh oh not not me it's I
guess I heard is listening to the stream
I'm playing at the same so he's the one
who's game and then they have hooker
rats that just like trap you and you
can't do anything your teammates happy
about and that's
somebody earlier on in the chat asked is
this game worth buying yeah it's like
only it's less than $30 on Steam nice
that's actually really good deal grab
someone grab the time okay cool so yeah
so that's one of the three tomes that
you can collect to raise your team score
by the end of it but it's it takes the
place of your healing drought so you
have to like put the tome down drink the
healing drought and then pick the tome
up again you can't carry both at the
same time I see so what does the healing
drug do it just gives you but it's a
better healer than the medical supplies
you can also heal your teammates if you
want see there's there's a game we got
right there what does the healing item
do chastity it fixes me have you guys
tried legendary yet it is insane no I am
NOT ready for that dude okay I'm not
ready for that so I've got my glaive I
crafted my glaive I really like it as my
melee weapon but then I also have this
bow let's see so I didn't targets how do
you feel about a bit different melee
weapons is there yeah there's a lot of
cool [ __ ] one that you don't like um no
I like I like em all you had like the
double swords you have the single sword
the single swords kind of it's not as
fast so I don't really prefer it so I
either for like two swords or the glaive
for vel satis thanks everyone has
different weapons nice hovering Sheldon
that's sorrentine we had like a boss
happening here while we're still getting
swarmed by boys there's a business
smaller rat on his back I mean
yeah they're gonna give her that smaller
oh no boy okay - away so why are these
rats so mean I don't know man they I
don't think they got all of his children
except pedaling it which is really
[Laughter]
throws fireballs but she can also
overheat so when you're playing as that
character you want to be careful
someone's down ere green some wounds
cannot be known by the elite route like
emotional trauma from seeing a shirtless
store I have a healing drought some
block and then man this is scary i
resurrecting your friends you want to be
sure to block otherwise they'll just
keep hitting you yeah yeah so is this
your first Warhammer game that you've
ever played yeah I tried a little bit of
the first room inside it was alright
this was a lot more fun yeah I so I
think a lot of people and they see the
Warhammer title they're a little like oh
whatever I don't know that's that thing
I mean that's the thing that I don't do
normally yeah and so maybe they get a
little bit scared like myself but this
is definitely not what I was expecting
yeah
the handmaiden has a really good dad
so chats what class are you playing I'm
playing the elf but specifically the
handmaiden so there's three versions so
it was the second one that you unlock
the third one being the shade they all
have different passive abilities so like
mine is I dash through my health is
super low but my god I love behind it
positivity there you were like I'm
optimistic but I need a healing drought
bad health I'm just gonna like you know
place this guy in the face
yellow man thank you thank you for doing
that alright now we can move on so
sometimes you it's usually one boss per
Matt but sometimes I ran into two last
night kay says he's gonna join the next
game he's having connection issues it's
not a felling yes so they have those
ammunition crates if you're the elf to
pick up some more arrows for your PO
nice can you pick up old arrows in the
gun oh now you just have to get the
either the ammunition and things laying
around or animation free it's gotta fill
them up can you customize character
appearance ask Bob Jones yeah you can
making more different outfits are there
can you change outfits once you've made
your character yeah absolutely
between all the games when you're in
that first starting area you just go to
customize and pick what all of your
weapons are and you have trinkets and
necklaces to buff you and then you can
also change up your outfit if you unlock
those outfits I got an outfit for the
elephants from playing the beta so that
was cool
NASA boy says is this game on sale for
consoles - I don't think it's one
console yet if I'm not mistaken so yeah
I don't I didn't think it was
if I'm wrong but I think I'm PC right
now I'll tell you but supposedly it's
coming to Xbox oh nice
you know Xbox is getting some decent
games people like to wait time yeah I
saw a comment I know we're playing a
vermintide right now but I have talked
about this because it was so crazy I'm
sure you all who are watching this know
that Drake played for a night last night
you did when I was playing for Amanda
yeah anyway I saw commented and it was
like somebody who was a for tonight fan
who was like yeah the only reason
playing for tonight's the street plan he
is for otherwise I'd be playing Hub G
and I was like you know going free to
play on ps4 was probably the best thing
that he never did my door anyway random
thoughts back suburban time yeah and
then they had these potions so I just
picked up a potion of strength to help
you temporarily I'm so how does that
buff work those potions yes so you
picked hit four and then you drink it
and then you're the strong temporary and
then extra strong I was could it be like
and then you're strong and then you're
so strong look at all these speed right
through and then that bleeds them I wish
and when is down wish we had a person
like that in real life only she's got
super strength bruise like a minute
like when you're just removing things by
yourself Pascal says well you were
publisher review for this game I don't
know I'm not sure I'm not anywhere near
the game's review team yeah I work on GS
universe usually so the reason that you
never see me as I'm on the entertainment
side of games yeah if you guys might as
well plug it right now you guys want to
see more chasity please subscribe to
GameSpot universe we talk about movies
and TV shows and fun stuff and yeah the
comment is great and you know you like I
love it I personally fell in love with
it you're down for Avengers infinity
where we have a lot of contact on your
way yeah you guys did a lot of great but
Panthers so I mean you're all on it so
check it out there's some questions here
who is drinking what is for tonight I
know in the hotline bling' yes I do
anything fried is 14 nights yeah oh
Stefano he says he wishes have a
stronger PC he missing a lot of good
stuff right now I love it I just built a
PC I bought pieces for it I've been
playing on gaming laptops verted I
finally made it y'all know I have my own
gaming PC now and I bought all the
pieces during Black Friday oh that's
more ever turning back how did you do
through the whole graphics card like
debacle um it was slightly before that
because uh cuz of Black Friday so it was
just regular price only price it was
regular the quickest thing happened I
guess in like January February yeah so I
I bought it late November so I was fine
I have a 1070 and I am okay I want to
get a 1070 right now I have a 916 but
it's still good like it definitely still
play this yeah absolutely
so we need to go up the ladder and get
that thing down Bush Andrew cat says one
question there is a game with vermin in
it question mark googly eyes
vermin here they are I don't know why
what I have against them but I've been
instructed to just kill them all so kill
them all I'm not really sure what they
did to me but they started attacking me
so I'm this is self defense they brought
this upon themselves but I'm having a
good time all right I like this little
Dorf man next he's still great that's
been that's been that's been been he's
so great looks like a badass he is a
badass he's so strong look at those
muscles he's got those tattoos you can
just tell so that's the tone is anyone
who says 1060 is a significant jump for
only $200 fYI okay yeah I'm definitely
considering him thinking about it I can
speed through these boys turn around and
then slice them and they've already
blood because I sped through that's my
army super for handmade aryl so was the
beat gaming PC given to you by shield no
I hadn't been part of shield at that
point I just got recruited yesterday
which was awesome the creepiest like
promo thing I've ever seen a knife gosh
darn life I'll tell you that he's a
dossier of everything we knew there was
a dossier of everything that's Josie
that's in my Facebook LinkedIn and
Twitter it's just like we noticed that
you're good at karaoke and we noticed
that you have a dog named this and this
is your boyfriend and these are people
I was like what are you doing carrying
the crap and these are your favorite
foods and we know where you were I was
like this is fine but also really
terrifying but thanks but thank you
thank you for scaring the crap out of HQ
but it was super weird because one of
the stars of the show had just followed
me on Twitter like two hours before and
then I got that dossier in the mail and
I was like in my injury yes you're in
shield pretty great I thought they
disbanded or a that says I can't wait to
play this in 4k off my Titan that time
I'm not using my Bo enough because I
just like also I don't know
who down down all right but yeah this is
a lot of fun I've been playing with
friends yeah Ben's playing so it's nice
that we play different characters
because you can't you can't have two
elves through an empty Dwarfs it's not
your it's Dutch we have to have one of
each Bush and Ryu cat says thanks ladies
and second hi are you happy as I I'm
just I think there's a typo in there but
are you happy as I am that drawl is a
character in Soul Calibur six
I need help though I think chastity is
what's up sorry you asked me no she's
doing important game things sorry what
do you ask me
well Bush and Ryu cat asks you are you
as happy as I am that drawl is a
character in Soul Calibur sex yes your
sounds dope as hell
it does sound dope it's it's an
unexpected crossover I wasn't I wasn't
seeing that happening yeah nice I never
expected that to happen that's really
cool but that's cool anything is
possible
yeah there's been a lot of weird
crossovers lately Street Fighter Monster
Hunter yes that happening yes seriously
were you and I'm also hunter is very
confusing to me but I'm into it yeah but
it's national we're here for it I'm here
for it I know were you and anything cuz
Rio was my main forever
I'm street fighter nice until it was can
just be Freddy five he's still your
heart I have a question about Romans
head here the different hordes like
different enemies that you encounter in
these words are some a lot harder than
others are they I'm sure I'm sure they
are but are they all equally dumb are
some smarter yeah no um some of them a
lot of these guys that you see right
here
equally done but then there's just
armored ones that are especially hard to
take down and especially hard to take
down and then you have those hooker rats
that just take you and then you can't do
anything about it your teammates have to
help you and then they have like this
Gatling gun rat which is super annoying
that you need to take out with a ranged
weapon so that's why you carry the melee
and the bow
nice alright and I wait for crippling
depression a says looking forward to
this game would you recommend buying it
in into the beta yeah it's it's
available yeah it's version to be the
full version it's on beta any more than
beta yeah it recently came out very
recently I forget the date but yeah i
was playing beta and all the sudden I
wasn't would you say that ben is a
friend or a frenemy that is great
man he's been used to work together at
IGN and now we're working together
getting spot and I would work with him
again a third time except we're gonna
stay here forever cuz GameSpot rules who
can spot the bad days look at oh boy
here they come yeah there he is see
that's the boy that I hate Oh God God
will be dashed out of the way that's out
of the way
shoot him shoot him is there a story
orgy you just run around and kill stuff
I've only been doing quick play but
there is a story so there is a story but
the best part I was running around and
killing stuff yeah I've only been
playing quick play so I not super
invested in the story
there are different modes though and
then there's a you can play with if
you're playing by yourself even not
playing with friends you can hook up
with other people that are playing as
groups there's a server nice and this
matches yeah yeah and that's there's a
lobby that you can find a bunch of
people that are playing on complete
games with rock with box and then you
can join their game if your characters
not taken now is it so they have it set
up so that it will always pull different
roles right and you won't like end up in
a game at but you pick your role yeah
you pick your role and then when you're
in the lobby and then you try to match
up with people you have to see what
which roles have already been taken
there will be X's over the rules that
have been taken so you have to choose a
match where your role hasn't been taken
unless you're willing to change who you
are
I am dying I'm gonna try to hide behind
I just got here now Chaz you didn't play
the original vermintide to do very
little very little of it very easy
before the Bourbon tatu baby got it so
somebody in the chat asking would you
say that this play is smoother or is
optimation about the same I can't I'm
not a good source for that because I own
I can tell you I own complete like twice
yeah so but I've heard that people that
play the first vermintide prefer this
game yeah just overall in general yeah I
had like one hit left I had no health
but I am carrying a tome so please
protect me Gatling gun rats is the new
top and awesomeness gallon gun read what
they called me
Gatling gun rack
can tell why because my name is
impossible we make him to claim for as
we disturb him yesterday everyone was
trying I was like I don't like any of
these new things do stuff did they give
you any ones in particular that you like
to share no she was calling me ChaCha I
was forget it now I brought this upon
I'll try really hard it's cuz everyone
was shortening to chess and then I no
one knew that I disliked that but I just
I tolerate it because it's happened like
all my life oh yeah I grew up with
called me chess but it's like my name's
got three syllables and I understand yes
so when you reach the bridge of Shadows
then you have finished that level so
you're victorious we did it well we are
we are so good at this game yes hi
everyone now I can say hello to you and
look you in the eye very briefly
well my score comes up oh yeah well yeah
I'm go to youtube.com slash games about
universe if you ever want to see our
videos is that I'm regularly on Scoob
just said chassé pass like the fish ok
bass version is alright I want like a
slap in the best yeah um look it's
upgrading my chest so you get cool stuff
in here you can get new weapons you get
new trinkets and necklaces that will
buff you and you get to keep them
forever yeah unless you craft them you
can use them to just melt them is the
crafting system difficult or easy in
your opinion it seems pretty easy I'll
show it to you if you want to see it but
I think my glades pretty good right now
ah yeah Oh decently but clearly everyone
was doing a little bit better than me
but I all my friends so see you get the
box after you you are successful and
then you open up your spoils of war
let's see what I got oh boy here we go
you did it you made a mistake by telling
your braid ChaCha there I know now
they're calling me ChaCha
yeah this is Shiva's fault really
ultimately I got a charm but it's the
same level as the one I have right now
and then I got another charm also thanks
I swear off three charms nice whatever
how does that make you feel like I did
all that work for three of the same
thing so you go over here to your forge
you open it up and so this is where you
can craft pick your talents so as you
see every five levels you can pick
different talents at level five I
increased my area for effective blocks
at level ten I cleared any wounds and
converted temporary health to permanent
health when the bosses died and then at
level 15 I further increased my dodge
distance so my Dodge is super good
because look at this I've already got a
passive of increased dodge distance nice
so yeah equipment I can see all the
charms I got cuz all I got was charms
this time around it's usually not the
case there's what I have equips but I
can move up and now I have yeh power
moved up to two so that's great very
exciting on up in the world
I've got my necklace which boosts my
health I'm gonna stick with my bow here
and then I'm gonna stick with my glaive
cuz I really like the glaive but as you
can see I also have like the sword and
dagger I have the single two-handed
sword nice elven spear dual swords good
stuff and then if you want to craft
stuff it's here but I'm not gonna keep
these guys waiting I was about to ask to
see the cosmetics but we'll wait yeah
cuz they want to know are we gonna see
any other maps yeah I hope so I really
hope it's a different map it's random
got it so recruits and we are gonna play
here we go
also hello oh good bgp he's one of my
viewers manga the stream welcome to
GameSpot please come again and also iron
praetor I saw you in here earlier wow
look at him he looks so great look he
put a shirt on
he no longer has his tattoos showing
he's got all his armor he's a classy no
classy
he's so armored up and he's got his
fancy shield great you look so nice he's
been able to talk now I think I can hear
him I was able to hear him before I
heard I heard him before - there's group
zero any likely emotes or any things
that you can do can you wait you hold on
do we have everyone oh we have everyone
so I don't know how to get him sorry Tay
sorry today we have because Morocco mole
stayed with us that's fine I wonder if
Morocco Mona knows that he's streaming
on GameSpot okay I'm trying not to all
right how do we boot all right no oh
that's so sad you gotta kick him out you
can't kick a random guy who's that this
is Morocco mole was playing with us in
the last round oh he wants to play again
that's fine yeah okay different map
pretty sure pretty sure there's a
different map yes it is okay yeah this
is the one with the barns max
Kuro says I have no clue what I'm
watching what is this game this is
vermintide - if you played left 4 dead
it's kind of similar that because you've
got a team of four you all are different
characters you can't have two of the
same character and you party and we go
around we kill a lot of rat boys we get
attacked by all these crazy deranged
rats some of them have hooks some of
them just try to bite you some of them
are just real mean yeah and then there
are some bosses - we've got trolls in
here we've got giant rats with little
rats on their backs it's crazy man we
got big rats we got smaller we got big
rats and small rats on the back yeah I
heard you like rats so I put a small rat
on your big rat
okay I'm in a field and I can barely see
these rats are there so I'm gonna use my
range
someone's behind me chaos we're good
look at him popping because he's count
pickles we need to beat tricks for your
account I have no idea how it happening
today
unless possible oh no permit I'd sue
which rapper would you want to stream
with the most
okay well it's he's not he's not like a
traditional like gas rat not really a
rapper but like Bootsy Collins would be
pretty funny Oh see that's the hook rat
see I can't do anything and so my
friends help oh that's very good
it's like everything's damn you her crap
how dare you so we've got a rat ogre or
snoop dogg snoop that would be awesome
right I agree so this is just a rat or
he doesn't have a small road on his back
keep my distance and dash away but he is
oh my god - the room here we go Oh No
- didn't work because he is too fast oh
god why is he after me specifically I
appreciate this like your attempt at
cutting here but he's just so much
faster slice him in the back oh never
mind I - the room no see he and when he
turned time to be try sidestepping
nice Oh friends those are rats worth it
they're kind of ladies up there like
definitely not completely alive but
something is wrong with them for sure
yeah it was pretty offensive like cheese
sorry but what else do you I'm really
enthusiastic about she's that makes
total sense but I didn't expect you to
be in good condition like I wanted to
eat it I went to Whole Foods yesterday
because I felt like being fancy and
there was Gouda samples hell yeah the
good Gouda it was there was a lot of
cheese there my friends all right good
all right and off we go yeah I'm having
so much fun playing this game I've
literally been playing it like for maybe
an hour or two now in three hours after
I go home every night this week after
work
this is the rat men's cheese farm cheese
farm it sounds like a dream that sounds
like my kind of place except for all
these big bad boys with weapons
crippling depression SS sending good
vibes from organ hi my brother lives in
or
I heard it's awesome I still have yet to
visit it oh man Eddie the new Portland I
have not been to Portland I have a my
uncle lives up there though and I've
been wanting to go visit for a while so
here it's a beautiful yeah I really
wanna check it out I heard there's great
food in Portland but thank you for
sending the good vibes yeah we're
sending them right back from San
Francisco and I don't care if I'm not
doing the best it's really hard to
scream and play I'm usually the host so
this is different for me yeah yeah I
used to have a huge complex about
playing on in streaming at the same time
I tried to do but yeah I would always
try to do both like reading chime
playing I give a lot of people that do
it oh it is so it can be really hard I
see stream League of Legends and the
only way you can really play that game
is by focusing by focusing really hard
but my chat always wanted to talk with
me it was very yeah and so it was hard
for me to like feel good about my
gameplay which is sort of the reason I
stopped so much with that one but I do
love streaming more casual games from
able to talk to chat yeah but do you
still play League of Legends um you know
I actually played recently a little bit
and I it's it's so fun there's a lot of
changes in the game they made it less of
like a carry a game where like one
person carries the whole team they're
trying to make it more like team centric
goods you know you would think good good
no you know I think that it's
frustrating for people who are used to
carrying their weight at the top of
ranked games interesting yeah but ya
know lately I have been staying away
from streaming League I did play a I
play a few games here in there
got'em nice I got was super armored so I
just had to dash like this it's not
gonna go well for me what church this is
I used to I used to have to remind Sam
to buy item ins and League because she
would read chat when she would go back
to Nexus in 1500 yes I was really I was
really bad at multitasking in that game
and it was very embarrassing but it's
nice when you have two people on stream
because you know one can mend the chat
and talk and hang out person could just
have fun which is like the nice thing
yeah yeah I like the two person balance
me too back on Portland for a minute
he says Portland heads up Portland is
90% bicycles you have like everybody
just riding bicycles instead of cars I
just pictured bicycles with googly eyes
the population is we have another
question here is there an ending to the
game or is it play play and replay so
this is quick play there's a story mode
also right
I believe so there's different modes but
I've only played quick play I don't have
too much intel on the others I played
the training that they force you to play
which had a little bit of story to it
but I barely know anything that's going
on I just know that I've got my three
friends here whoa a pig lamb Joey the
rats have not eaten him he's not cheese
yeah he's not they only eat cheese okay
I have a little bit of respect for those
rats then they didn't hurt that pig says
me who loves bacon I'm just gonna follow
Ben he seems like he knows where all
these books are
Phillipe Ben's really good at singing
hymns like understanding where to go and
that's like good at games
oh yeah she's pretty metal look at the
way she's dressed
rugby says quick play just drops you in
the games there are acts though and you
can follow them in order for the story
mode thank you like I'm just having so
much fun and quickly that I don't really
want to play the story but I guess can
you play as a rat character no we go
back down oh boy that's a horde and they
are coming we say we see the pig in Auto
Justin chat goes bacon heals all wounds
hell yeah reminds me of the time that I
drove by this is like oh man it's you
know it's suits it's too cruel if
there's any vegetarians in the chat
please close your ears sorry we drove by
a truck of it was on a road trip when I
was a teenager with my friends family
sure by truck of cows and my friend look
at the van when feel I don't know just
remind me you brought me back to that
moment where we looked at the house and
said meet thank you all charges for
bringing that home impact they can sell
a good though but bacon is oh Jesus I'm
sorry I'm sorry doll the Piggy's out
there I really want some right now you
know I actually I attempted to be a
vegetarian for a few years and dinner
speaking for a long time when I first
start eating it again
it was seasoned really salty it took a
while for me to get back in but now it's
a weeknight it's we're broke back to
square one with it being a
very big weakness yeah so there's gonna
be a boss right behind this barn door I
believe but there's also a book up here
but okay wait I don't know if anyone
knew it so the book is so there are
three tomes to collect Scott it and then
there are two Grimm's to collect and
those are harder to find those are the
more rare books I'm forget where the
book is here if anyone knows Ben where's
the book you might be trying to get it
if you watched what he's doing I think
he's trying to find it I just know it's
you have to climb up one of these and
it's in here somewhere but Wow then feel
free to yell at me in the text/chat if
you need me to get it but for now I'm
just gonna guard down here cuz I don't
know where the book is Ken at this point
in time is there just gonna be a break
here where you can look you're supposed
to be looking for the tombs or no the
next part is in this barn nice be a boss
that walks out I see so we unlock that
we want to try to get the book because I
know there is one here is he standing by
it
oh boy here comes a swarm alright so
that's what I was gonna ask you don't
know if we want the second no but it's
here okay cool um I'll make my way
towards you I'll have those guys try to
guard and I will come rebby so don't
grab it until after the boss is dead
alright cool thank you grab the book
after the boss got it I'll take your
advice I trust you you seem like a
stand-up Jim Tom oh boy
oh boy I let my support of the traders
having me tips and not just letting me
die and I really appreciate that help me
oh wow it says also it lowers your
health for the rest of the mission
there's a reason so it's better to do it
afterwards because you grab the book
before your health will be lower cool
thank you good to know yeah there's so
many maps I'm just like figuring it out
but I'm having so much fun all right who
picked up the key 20 my mom used to tell
me that she would buy me snacks brought
me vegetables and said vegetables are
snacks they're just you know really
healthy snacks they really want you
seriously this this oh my god oh my god
in my head oh my god no all right okay I
was terrible see I was saying I was
chilling but now I'm no longer - I
thought that this happened to me yeah I
thought I was gonna take a lot more of
your health and it did to be honest yeah
that looks pretty pretty little that
probably should have taken were like
yeah keep my distance
and let him cook in the fire Alberto
Rodriguez she is playing with mouse and
keyboard yes oh my god why oh no that's
gonna I must be delicious cuz he's just
eating the crap out of my head what is
he really he looks like an alien
he's the spawn of chaos that's his name
that's a pretty badass yes I am the
spawn of chaos yeah look at my tongue
arm is a tongue
do you have any handling drought you're
gonna die no I have no healing job Oh
keeping my distance cuz I have no
feeling right now like I swear nieces no
you're he's really close all right get
him in the back nice nice nice
oh yeah you know I tried to be a hero
that's what happens I should have just
been a coward so winging him around with
his tongue arm
he's down it's fine everyone's okay all
right now get the book
I need healing really bad as anyone have
Ewing they can't please help me
did you have a were you saving your
arrows there in the end yeah for him but
I think I ran out c09 I'm out but I use
them all on the boss no one answered me
so I guess there's no healing it's okay
all right well arrows would be great
right here because I have the high
ground like obi-wan Kenobi but
unfortunately oh you got one for me oh
thank you
earlier they wouldn't win that guy when
he had grabbed you and like nibbled on
your head there it was not nice it was
like that was a bad time there's an
armored rat right there so he's much
somebody said that was disgusting and it
went on for way too long
seriously I'm very uncomfortable after
watching oh happy twice so oh my that
moment when no one wants to heal you
gave me a potion it was very nice of him
that's like I feel like that's me and
pub G when I let go through all of my
first aid kits and I'm like you know
anything it's okay I can fight my way
through the swamp so what are you
playing right now me yeah it has been
battlegrounds I'm addicted jeez I know I
haven't I only played a little bit since
the big update there was a huge update
bad emotes they okay any mutts are we
talking about you know I haven't looked
at them yet babe they literally just oh
no it was a huge update was like a Mayan
gig update damn yeah you crates some new
items they changed some of the actual
visual like visuals in-game like when
you go to scope an enemy like the entire
visual animations
so Wow nuances do you like the updates
yeah I haven't played enough of it yet
what I will say is that I recently
started playing a lot of first-person
and I enjoy it more than third oh really
yeah that's cool um I like first for at
first I was really not turned off the
first person cuz I just thought it was
more difficult but then I realized that
you died - really stupid and frustrating
things in third person because of all
the peeking and first person selling I
had a better competitive advantage so
but yeah with that said it's a lot more
fun for viewers like if I'm streaming it
for them to watch third person so you
know I don't know I'm curious to see
what I think what do you guys prefer
yeah curious oh they're mad about the
emotes lame emotes unnecessary those
u-boats don't fix bugs I could have
gotten arrows ouch
hold on Ben I'm getting arrows don't go
too far thank you
this guy says about I think he's talking
about vermintide here this game is
awesome definitely thirty bucks it is I
think I paid like 26 something at the
time it might have been on sale for like
a day or two but it's completely worth
it Stephano is the spawn of chaos should
put a shirt on like a dork dressed maybe
a dress
Seanna I got you horray says this game
in 4k is awesome and I believe you
everything in 4k is awesome I wish had a
4k TV
I bought a 4k TV 4k TV
I did oh my god but not for gaming cha
cha oh my god no it's really [ __ ] I
want a 4k TV yes yes definitely
movie night yes movie night we can watch
some on the marble step before Avengers
infinity war rev B says I've been
obsessing this game it is 8 the last it
is I'm having so much fun
add me if you want to play together
did you guys end up getting the book
yeah up there now we're too far gone
it's fine
got it
we have one book so we're fine nice
whatever you don't even need to get him
to finish work it's just nice to have
this is so much going on and my head got
eaten twice like I got a free these
prisoners like look at these poor boys
what did they do to you what do those
poor rats to do see I'm a hero shadow
slash gaming welcome he said I've never
seen this game before it looks cool
what's it about room said - it's similar
in left4dead
up you play with a party of four total
you can't overlap characters there's a
lot of rats that it's all about you
smashing rats just smashing rats killing
the boss of rats there's multiple maps
that you play into it's a lot of fun I
play with your friends my strangers my
only levels of character and like barely
love about is the self I'm I've been
trying to close Siena but it's tough
Pablo says this feels like Skyrim or it
sounds like Skyrim plus destiny you know
that's not a bad comparison it sounds
like a cool combination yeah I mean it's
like you know elements from both for
sure I mean more waves of enemies right
you got the Destiny thing yeah and but
it kind of looks Skyrim II right we're
in like an old fantasy world yeah I
guess that's the put that's an aesthetic
it has the aesthetic but that's really
where the comparison stops is a Skyrim
comparison it's yeah it's leopard up
with the Skyrim aesthetic yeah yes
that's it that's the more perfect
comparison
is free these guys free these boys
I heard that valve is making more games
again yeah that's the word on the street
yeah I don't know what Street but that's
the word it's very exciting
Chris Hanson says what do the books to
do besides saving cancer
To Catch a Predator Chris Hanson 69 what
did the books ooh they just it's it's
kind of hard to play with them because
when you pick them up or can't pick up a
healing drought so you have to like stop
put the book down and take the healing
droughts then pick the book back up but
it levels up your score by the end of it
which is an added bonus
it boosts your to score at the end of
the play marks beaming you to level up
to certain skills faster right yeah that
makes sense
else's random things when she does that
- is a greatness
so chastity hey where was your or
cha-cha I mean okay what's up I'm
warming up to it when you say I promise
I will never call it a cha cha I know
you're doing it ironically I am I'm
chill today is the only day I get to do
it I'm on this dream right now yeah I'm
chill with it I will not take it out
over this room I promise
and I apologize if anybody else today
cause no one died we have all of our
team members we are so victorious we're
so good at this game
yes I'm giving a lot of credit to Ben I
do okay the door carry but sorry you had
a question for me I did by the fact you
called me ChaCha
well I was gonna say what was the first
game that you played with friends like
not cooperatively in person because in
the beginning all gaming multiplayer was
like couch co-op technically yeah but
like what was yeah right like what was
the first game online that you played
with friends that like you guys would
jump online a lot together anyway okay
so I had I was very terrified to play
online for many years and I actually did
not play online with people I didn't
know until very recently got it not
until I joined IGN so like very late in
life because I was terrified cuz like I
like once people heard I was a girl or
once my friends did that like I saw what
happened to them I just yes terrified so
you turn off by it
yeah I'm not great so I was turned off
by it like I'm I'm not this going to be
your strongest ally so I'm probably
gonna get [ __ ] so I just like would not
talk and sometimes when I do play online
I just don't talk at all like yeah like
when I'm in overwatch I'm talking
overwatch at all
I don't talk I usually just text yet but
what about so like I guess like the way
that you play with friends and firm and
tied to do you have other games that you
like to play with your friends
yeah oh yeah we were talking like
killing floor - so I I was playing that
killing lot more recently yeah because
then I switched it out with vermin
so killing floor overwatch is one of
them I still play with friends
what else do I still play with friends
I've been trying to play dragon ball
fighters of friends but they make it
really difficult it's just hard to like
actually play with someone it's like you
have to be in the same like place and
then you have to like set up this bubble
and then you walk into and it's like
this is too much do you think that
that's why the player numbers dropped on
that game pretty hard for in the
beginning probably it is difficult yeah
it was just super difficult
I like the glaive I'm gonna stick with
it but if you want to see the crafting
so see I can craft a new Glade here I'm
gonna do that and then you just craft
some which I melted all my like old
underpowered gear to craft it and now it
is a one away clave excellent into it
I'm gonna use it and then I'm gonna
stick with this bow because this one
only has 16 in the quiver stick with
this necklace stick with this charm so
good this trinket stéfano an incredible
amount of rats were harmed in the making
of this game an incredible amount of
rats a lot of rats there's my hero
oh oh here oh he's great okay here we go
one more quick play stick with recruit
because I just don't want to fail for my
last okay how much time do we have left
we have well we've been in for an hour
so I would say 30 minutes more okay so
probably one more map nice I'm assuming
some people in here was sharing some of
their favorite multiplayers team
fortress that was a big one I've missed
the team fortress bow I did too
but one that's pretty broad that I can
play with pretty much anyone is
overcooked nice oh okay so everybody's
been talking about overcooked
we totally wanted to play it on the
Women's Day stream by the way but we we
that's an obvious joke right right
please the joke makes itself we could
have made the joke ourselves but it was
just too much
was just too much and with a bunch of
women in the kitchen huh haha yeah
alright we did it itself we did it for
you guys so we had a lot of fun that was
a great stream it was fun for hosting
that yeah you too you'll be both hosted
and it was really cool that we everybody
came together and that we I we were able
to get all the women and basically
almost everybody - Angela from
engineering and Elissa on social
international international squad but
they almost everybody was there which
was pretty cool yeah a great time if you
guys want to watch that it's still the
bot is still live and I'll probably
imitate if you're watching the spot
right now yep yeah and in the game spot
there should be a little like OOP right
now more questions trying to go through
some of them here more levels yeah I'm
having fun watching this well caste is
having cha-cha is having fun playing was
like if you camera was not on right now
you against Eva Rev visas try the spear
in the office well if you like the
glaive oh yeah Khalil of the Spirit I
played with the sphere I like it I like
the glaive more but the spear is pretty
dope as well maximum Minaj says how well
there's Nikki brother of Nicki Minaj
says how would you rate the difficulty
of this game and then what do you do
really hard a seven I was confused by
that it gets really hard yeah I've only
clean up to veteran and veteran still a
challenge for me because you don't start
with the healing drought it's really
hard to find healing droughts you die
pretty fast and I commonly do not finish
levels in veteran so I like I'll finish
a level every other time so I guess
50/50 but I'm gonna try to move up to
the next level after that which just
seems
hard for me right now so I might try to
see look at him he's a jerk how dare
Chris Hansen says Ben's got all the
moves he does who is hurting my friend
Wow he looks strong Wow he looks strong
[Music]
Stefano's is how many different enemy
types are in the game I don't know the
total but I've seen like the minion type
of guys the minion type of rats the
armored rats the chaos warriors that
these guys they have the hook rats then
you got your your gas rat you got your
guy who just like makes weird green
tornadoes there's the Gatling gun round
yeah Gatling gun around yeah rats on
backs on backs patrol the big ol rat
that doesn't have a round on his back
what you do Ben what did you do
we also scared means that I made a
mistake
uh-huh sivanna says also is this like
left for dead where multiplayer can
control the enemies or nah I had sent
out an apology to maximum ah she says my
name is not spelled the same do not
relieve if that other person are we
apologize this is gonna be the day where
I make everybody upset with the names I
call them but yeah last week was awesome
I'm really glad that we had a chance to
highlight the women behind the scenes
that helped produce the videos that
helped make the site keep the site
running help support the content yes
there's so many awesome people that work
at GameSpot and I love all of them yeah
this is really it's been oh it's a
family it's a work family yes definitely
everybody is very supportive and good to
each other here yeah I know it sounds
like I'm drinking the kool-aid but I
really do
yeah we're I mean it's cool we can drink
kool-aid you know it's it's genuine yeah
definitely
who's standing there oh that's that's a
real muscular rat strong rat we just
call him strong and strong rat I will
will you take damage from fire like that
yeah if the fire was caused from an
explosion but if it's CNS fire I'm good
would this be a time to break out your a
way oh okay I'm going to use mr.
inclusion I that was the best drink that
was a bad time to drink it nice smack
him in the bag it was a language diaper
it was very strong rat wearing like a
parrot eyes he's wearing a diaper
Oh Daniel II I hope you enjoy your tacos
I love tacos
I had Mexican twice yesterday and I
don't regret that amazing yeah I had
tacos for dinner and I had burrito for
lunch
it's delicious what are your favorite
tacos let me know in the chat
I feel like Taco Bell is delicious or is
it junk food I mean it's junk food but
like it's definitely just a tasty so I
used to be on the like why the heck
could you eat Taco Bell when you could
have real Mexican food camp and then I
realized it was a perception issue and I
should stop perceiving Taco Bell like
Mexican food and it says yeah I'm saying
its own thing and then this is I would
enjoy it more and now I do really like
taco yeah I just a crunch wrap supreme
is so far from what you don't think no
no it's on screen this is not sponsored
by taco but we're just a bunch of
garbage beat us up I'll eat the taco oh
no life
yeah yeah talk about you know let us
know what's this thank goodness alright
I'm having so much fun and I'm glad that
Ben is here carrying the team and making
us look good I'm doing my best but I'm
pretty average Alvarado says tacos out
past or hell yeah you're pretty good
those are delicious shoot him in the
butt shoot him in the butt it Stefano
Taco Bell product placement all the
sudden I'd like to talk about social
team like walks in with tacos like right
now that'd be amazing
besides Taco Bell what did you hear your
food besides talk about my favorite food
that's so hard okay this is gonna sound
kinda lame but I really love sandwiches
like just great I'm like a huge sandwich
feel like I'm toasted do you like more I
like cold and hot sandwiches okay I like
sandwiches right actually remember that
time we went into really cheap sub place
yes yeah yeah
so even like even though that is like a
very low tier sandwich yeah I'm like so
happy to eat that low to your sandwich
like I love sandwiches I like ya know
I'm a real picky
I'm not a I'm not a real picky eater I
do obviously have some things I like and
don't like but yeah yeah I like a
variety of yeah I eat mostly everything
I don't like cilantro because it's that
weird pH balance thing where it tastes
like soap to me yes yes some people get
that yes
if for some people it's so unfair for
some people it's other things I'm not
sure which brat this guy was talking
about but he goes oh that was a hairy
way the street is making me really
hungry
[Laughter]
now we're talking I was just talking
about sandwiches for a really long time
we were talking about bacon exactly
because we saw that pig and I packed
lunch today and it's so act it's tuna
fish crackers well what if you bought a
soup to go with it and then you would
definitely make it better probably
totally not adjacent pork chops are the
bomb I agree but I do love look wait
rebby apparently made a french
joey tribianni and apparently I don't I
forget where yeah he made a friend's
reference and you know I'm here for it I
love friends I love friends that was
like my I've probably watched friends
seasons 1 through 10 easily ten times
over amazing do you have a favorite
episode yes our favorite friend it's in
the very beginning though I think it's
the first season there's an episode of
where there's a blackout and Chandler
yes yes yes the ETM he had second ATM
vestibule with that model I forget her
name but that episode is so good it's
such a good scene on episode also the
one where Ross gets a spray tan yes
that's a great episode and the one where
he waiting since the lot yeah that the
teeth and then he goes and sits with her
and if there's a black light and he just
looks ridiculous yes and my favorite
definitely characters probably Ross
because he's just like a punching bag
he's just a fan of every joke I love it
so many people hate Ross yeah I love
Ross Ross all day I'm glad he has some
support I love Joey I also like shadow
slash gaming said this is supposed to be
about
the game how did this devolve into spa
codes and sandwiches and bacon didn't
forget don't forget the pig friends okay
so this map is this this is a new map
from the last when you played this
wasn't in the beta but yeah this is a
new map we played three different maps
today this is this is a much grosser map
yes Bobby we're talking about the dead
bodies in the farm stuff it might be I
forget there two of them this one and
one other one looked very similar but
there's one we used to follow a trail of
corpses it's all starting to blend
together
I think big
I think goob and Denzel voice just went
my man yeah sorry about all the food
talk but is you girls honking up an
appetite
pork pastry because I saw a pig a pig
and I thought about the bacon oh that my
race yeah he just jumped on me I meant
to use my glaive that's fine how you've
lost tomorrow
my health is low but I am here for my
friends always you have any healing no
not on me right now I'm gonna keep an
eye out Ben if you see a feeling it's
funny this wasn't very spooky until I
looked at the skulls in the ground now
it's a horror game yeah and did you see
when the guy was eating my head twice
cuz that's when it was a straight horror
game here that was scary it was just
disgusting it's pretty brutal whoa I
almost sped right off the cliff thank
goodness there was a bush there when
that happens would you respawn oh no you
have to run back up it sucks that's
realistic but yeah if I die like if I if
I die I'm on the ground for a while
until someone revives me and then if I
just if my life runs out then they have
to find my body like I I'm tied up
somewhere on the map Bob Jones says we
need chassis to find cheese the cheese
room again so I know about cheese yeah
yo you want to talk about cheese and how
I miss it because I became lactose
intolerant late in life I still eat it
though I take latte at night I love
cheese
demon gave me 56 welcome to the street
you just came from school how are you
guys what's your favorite cheese let me
know in the chat hit me up on Twitter at
chasity underscore V tell me about
cheese we're we're doing good today
we're playing some which is a which is a
Warhammer game I feel like the Warhammer
is such an afterthought it's like right
like it's like wow wow this is actually
Warhammer game because I forget I
halfway through this dream forgot it
this is a Warhammer game and I hit the
switch then no I'm not throwing shade a
war hammer here but for me that makes it
definitely I forget where to go then you
know the game is much more accessible
than I would ever perceive a Warhammer
game be super excessive
you don't have to be a big fan of the
series yeah I got to jump into this this
is definitely a game for anything I
don't consider myself a big fan of the
series and I jumped right into this if
you want to see a rat
Oh on his back yeah yeah if you want to
slay rats with your friends outbreak
name ups that's exactly what I was gonna
say you do there good try to snipe the
little rat I'm gonna sweep through them
try to get behind him get get that
little rat off his back oh boy
nice nice
shoot that Laurette oh shoot it Wow it's
a little round little baby routers back
I'm entering I'm in a tree purpling
depression yeah most time you've ever
put into a game I personally put 3,500
hours into warframe Killing Floor 2
that's mine the most hours at pen
persona meme was probably this is hard
for me so my would have to easily be
League of Legends because it's
definitely like a thousand hours but
because I played it for like damn seven
years or something and it was like damn
right you got me beat but I don't but
like it's hard to tell because when I
was a kid I was really obsessed with
super mario 64 yes oh my god I spent so
much time playing mario 64 yeah about
that and I played it for like years
yes like I would like plug in my 64 I
had like a ps2 and it's like really
reliable it's like you know what I'd
rather click some stars right now yeah
but this is nice but what if I just went
back to diode our doubts
yeah and so I definitely put a good
couple hundred hours in that game hell
yeah no yeah that's definitely one of
them that I spent a lot of time in as
kids yeah so it's hard no regrets but no
regrets but yeah recently in terms of
like recent years it was personified for
me over a hundred hours and Killing
Floor 2 over a hundred hours
thanks
Chris Hansen says they both closeted
warhammer fans quote if you want to slay
rats of your friends will sound like
something psychotic out of context
y'all want to slay rats yo ass ladies
and rats tonight ya gonna be the rat
Slayer chance come says don't forget
your special ability to launch three
guided arrows no that's that's not I'm
playing the handmaiden my yeah okay so
that's not your that's not me no that's
the first version of the L let's see I
see you've been watching I'll use it on
a group but when I hit F Wow and it
bleeds him oh look at that I've been
doing my specials nice butts thanks for
looking out and it I like it because it
regenerates super fast like way more
than the three guided arrows for the
first version of the elf yes oh I need
it I need it I need it can I have it
thank you oh there's healing for
everyone we're good yeah okay
real line okay so this is tricky
usually we let one person realign it
there's this thing in the middle has to
be realigned and then everyone else
protects them so Ben if you want to do
it I'll protect you I'll have your back
see he's realigning this and then we
have to protect him so if you can do it
otherwise
boy these guys special ability check my
friends oh that right I had one arm man
I feel bad now
not really no don't lose he was gonna
kill me Chris may have been such a small
bro all right we have to go to the other
one where is he he's up there okay
running to you sorry
we're coming we're coming this is a good
example of teamwork in this game you
can't do this on your own
let's start coming on the wall except
for the milk all right there we go
okay there's gas up there I think we got
it right okay so what is this part in
the game here so this is the end of this
level so this is a special thing where
we we have to just kind of finish this
puzzle ah are we aligned it's now
survive until the alignment is completed
but there were three things that get to
a line right here in the center and then
you had to protect your friend while
they were doing it and now we just have
to survive survive the hordes oh that
was brutal I just was in science I don't
think he's gonna come up from that
someone is dead
hooray the balance is restored yes
amazing I'm so excited for Avengers are
you even saying that yeah yeah it's so
apparent about teamwork you know came
out super teens right yeah that's
definitely the Avengers and apparently
the trailer is dropping tomorrow that's
the word that's the rumor because there
was that tweet yes so people are like
yeah so it wasn't today we were hoping
it might be today yeah possibly tomorrow
we'll see exciting exciting time cuz if
the movie is coming out on yeah I was
gonna say the original date but yeah
that's exciting
I can't wait for tickets to go on sale
I'm looking forward to I feel like so
I'm actually an outlier and I don't I
didn't love the first Avengers film and
I are there Marvel films that you love I
actually like most of them I do I do
love most Marvel films and for some
reason I feel like even just the first
plot wasn't that who can save it was a
lot of fit it was just a lot of
fanservice saying yeah it was it was
definitely a fanservice movie because it
was just the chance to see all these
characters that they had start
developing team up for the first time so
that's really what it was but if you're
just like jumping in yours like you you
have nothing invested you're like okay
that's nice right it's just a lot of
fanservice but Infinity Ward looks
really interesting to me because the
last couple of years of MCU films have
been like the bar as raised I'm
tremendously
I can't they're incredible right well
Ragnar owe me yeah I'm a Toronto
Ragnarok was amazing like so there's so
many great films leading up to this one
that I think that it's gonna be much I'm
much stronger movie so I'm really
looking forward to it I'm just wondering
how they're gonna balance all the
characters in the MCU and the ventures
in right so there's two movies so maybe
we won't see some of them or some of
them will get like very minimal screen
time right with like a leave to the next
one sure and then they'll show up in the
second one but yeah I expect a lot of
characters to die yes
and I expect they're gonna kill off some
people and my prediction is Iron Man's
gonna die yeah there's gonna be a little
see if Robert engineer months let go
that page I mean like contracts nearly
up so yeah I feel like he's done Oh
actually what Simon if we might not have
time to yes so we it's 1222 okay yeah
we've been here for a little over an
hour
we could probably and the stream I think
I think here is probably good yeah if
you guys have any other questions we'll
take a moment with you guys now hold on
yeah we'll take some questions here till
12:30 just camera
oh hello oh hello it's us yeah did you
have fun I had fun
I love playing vermintide - yeah special
thanks to Ben for carrying me yeah shout
out to Ben sorry - yeah this was cool
I'm definitely gonna pick it up and play
I already have the game downloaded yes
definitely we'll play maybe we'll play
again on stream next week I don't know
what we're gonna be playing next
Thursday but you know let me know guys
in the comments below
yo see me because I'm rarely on GameSpot
yes if you want to check out more
chatzi's content GameSpot universes
where it's that they're gonna be doing
lots of Avengers content so if you're
into the conversation we just had
definitely check that out also real
quick top three cheese's go ok uh
mozzarella yes specifically burrata and
then I'm really into Brie
okay and I also like goat cheese ooh
nice I would say number one cheese
cheese cast it's not I I also have to
say mozzarella I love mozzarella so much
but you're from New York I'm from New
Jersey that makes sense we know what
good - yeah yeah you can't do that
normally here and then I would also say
cheddar I'm a big cheddar fan chatter is
good love me some cheddar and then Gouda
I'm all about that good there are no
wrong answers here Sam's all good no
wrong answers
we definitely cuz the rats you know it's
like rats it's it's somatic we're
talking about rats
another good rat was um Master Splinter
rat out there I would say twitch from
League of Legends my favorite oh yeah
rats and game they go rats and games
best rats and games we did it
gallery suggestion anyway thank you guys
so much for joining us today
it's a pleasure as always you can see us
here every day at GameSpot
from 11 to know we tried normally hit
around one we're kind of a little early
today probably because we're both really
really hungry after all that food talk
I need bacon yeah and cheese
we'll see you guys tomorrow and I will
see you guys next Thursday
alright bye everybody and